[Applause]
can everybody hear me okay okay perfect
um so today I was gonna do this talk
with Peter at them my boss but he
decided that he needs to go on the
vacation so so I'm doing this myself and
I prepared everything myself as well so
today are the subject would be data
pipeline with mono repo and kubernetes
are any of you data engineers around
here does anybody do anything with
deployments okay
so anyone actually are doing anything
with mono repo or kubernetes nice I
guess it's not gonna be so um this for
some people than this time so first let
me introduce myself so um I work as a
software engineer at thought machine
infrastructure team mostly I'm dealing
with built systems and deployments or
developer tools or CI CD and I
previously worked as a data engineer
mostly working on ETL and data pipelines
on AWS but at that time I didn't really
do much about like automatic automated
deployments and everything is kind of
manual actually so here is what happened
um so we had like I work in a specific
data team so it's called data lots and
so we have a separate stream of
deployment from the main applications
including stuff like our front end or
our API everything was like quite
separate and the main issue there was
like the deployments and so basically
sometimes would be like all the things
run some
machine but whenever or on the even on
the development environment but when we
promote it to production it just fails
like we didn't know why and so a lot of
times where we spend a lot of time
actually trying to figure out why and
then most of the times it's because of
some kind of dependency issues or
compatibility issues or just some little
configuration errors that we made and
but still like it was quite
time-consuming and or a sudden one of
our clients requested okay we don't want
the data pipeline our data to be on AWS
because we assigned a contract with this
and that help provider so we were like
okay now what do we do everything we
have is on AWS and so basically we had
to read you everything on from scratch
and so like I didn't really know
anything about mono repo um until I
think knit this year I think there are
some so does anybody actually know what
it is okay anybody use it okay so
basically it's the idea of kind of
having all your project in one
repository I know it kind of sounds kind
of crazy right like um because
especially nowadays modern technologies
would be focusing on micro services and
then you would be thinking like if I
have everything on one repository do I
have to kind of clone everything onto
every single instance or VM of mine or
every single docker container actually
the answer is no and it's being actually
being used by these companies and then
so there the misconception is um like
you have to get clone everything and but
that's not actually the case and so like
but the thing is like you don't have to
actually deploy the code
and so you only need to deploy artifacts
that for example binaries and so you
actually don't check in your code you
build the specific parts of your
repository and deploy it unto containers
or VMs and so the advantage of mono repo
is you don't really need to define what
projects are anymore you just kind of
make specific tools for specific things
and then you can decide that later on
and also it's really good scalability
and and like some of the stuff for
example we have like specific tools like
common tools you can just import it from
other for any other projects and you can
only even just use like one file and for
example if you want something for let's
say AWS but some other applications
around GCP you can just use like just
one file for like AWS and don't that
though that artifacts and deploy onto um
your any type of thing you want and it's
really easy to refactor as well since
it's only in like one repository and so
with mono repo like I mentioned that you
deploy artifacts so you all need to use
a build system anyone actually used
anything with built systems what do you
use
yes yes yes um so yeah basil is actually
an open-source version of place and now
talk about that later actually so how do
they actually work if you have never
heard of it I explain it step by step so
everybody knows how everything how a
built system actually works so basically
it's like given a git repository
contains a lot of source code in our
case it would be like a mono repo and
the built system would just like um
following specific instructions they'll
convert the source code into artifacts
it could be anything like executable or
binary just anything you can just run
with a command and or start up a service
or anything like that and so I mean as
Matt mentioned before it follows
specific instructions so we would need a
build file and it's kind of like a
series of high-level rules like most of
the times it's just like a function that
you call for example Python binary
Python test and the built rules convert
the source the sources into the outputs
which are usually are artifacts some
like they're always there's executable
except for libraries or other things
maybe tests and that's an example of the
a built file so you can see that I'm
there they're actually the it's taking
their source and also like it taken
takes the dependencies and the
dependencies are another thing that's
called a built target so it points to
specific directory structure and a
specific built label as well and so
basically the benefits of the build
system is um so we can actually know
what kind of third-party libraries we
have so like the kind of dependency
issues that I mentioned earlier would be
easily
resolved and we don't have to worry
about like incompatibility between the
development environment and production
environment and especially when the
clients ask okay what kind of
third-party dependencies did you use for
this application I need to know
everything so - for security reasons and
we usually we can usually provide them
that with just like our bill files for
third-party libraries and also you can
use since everything is like though this
is all the outputs are binary so you can
actually have different languages in
your repository actually we do that at
salt machine and so you don't have to
and also obviously don't need to clone
everything into your containers and it
also checks slices and as well so here
is the kind of history of the systems or
like choices of built systems someone
mentioned place early or base or earlier
it's like an open-source version of
place and but it's not actually that
similar to place and for Facebook and
Twitter they have their own open source
build systems as well and they are quite
similar and but I think each of them
have different things to do with their
specific system as well
and we have actually our own system
called please and so basically you can
run commands like please build with
actually plz it's quite funny the first
time when they saw it I actually didn't
think was real and so it's quite fast on
for Python for building Python binaries
and see buying to see past past minor is
it's actually faster than anyone any
other build systems on it's written in
go and so we can do quite a lot of on
concurrent processes and obviously I'm
one of the main contributors to this
system as well
and so now we have our artifacts built
by the built systems we need to worry
about deployments let me introduce you
to darker and I think some of you erased
your hands when I asked about docker
containers right ok
so for those of you who have who have
not used them basically think of it as a
box or a container kind of packages up
your code source code or your
configuration and stuff but in our case
it's just our artifacts and some
configuration or like environment
variables it can run anywhere and on any
cloud usually we use docker file as to
build images or run containers and so we
don't have to worry about the
configurations or don't have to remember
any kind of configuration details
anymore so that's the difference between
the container and DM as you can see it's
kind of different and VMs are actually
running on like kind of running
different systems on a single machine
and then docker containers you don't
actually need to that base OS anymore
and it's quite it's a lot cheaper to run
docker containers that way as well so
that's an example of a docter file
basically it just install everything you
want into a container and you run your
copy specific specific binary so
artifacts from your local machine to the
the container and it's basically kind of
like a virtual file system I guess um
and then you run the command and when it
starts up it kind of just a specific
service just starts help right away
and with docker containers especially
with micro services we would have need a
way to manage everything so when you
should use kubernetes to
managed containers any of you use
kubernetes I think have you asked before
awesome
so it's like the reason why we use it is
because we can just easily have
kubernetes to worry about how actually
everything cut is deployed and and all
we do need is just to create a specific
controller all requires controllers and
to control each and individual
containers and we don't actually we
don't even need to worry about
containers anymore and so this is like
an architecture of how kubernetes
kubernetes cluster is like we have a
master and and some and a bunch of
minions and they're called nodes and
inside of notes there are different pods
and inside of the posits containers but
usually we don't need to worry about the
containers anymore it's like a bit on a
2 level which you lower level site for
kubernetes you don't most of the times
you don't even need to worry about most
of the stuff on this anymore just the
structure so there are a few concepts so
with pods so it's like I mentioned
before it's like a smallest deployable
units think of it kind of like beams but
you don't actually need to worry too
much about it
in terms of individual pots because we
usually imagine them with a controller
which will I'll get into that later on
so all the containers actually share the
same kind of namespace and CP your
memory inside of the pot and usually
it's like disposable if any of you used
ec2 instances that's like you should be
disposable and ephemeral and pods are
kind of like that too and then then we
have services and so services are kind
of like um selects on specific parts
based on their key value pair like their
labels
and that's what you usually called
microservices and so we can have a lot
of services running at the same time and
this is usually used for like service
discovery or like um load balancing
because you can have duplicated cut pods
or services as well and next one is
deployments that's actually something we
do you need to worry about so it's like
I mentioned before it's a type of
control controller that manages pull
paths and replica sets and then you just
need to tell that how many what kind of
images you need what image you need to
create these containers and how many
pods do you need and how should they
roll out and then the resources and
everything else as well and then this is
kind of like an example of what a
deployment file configuration file for
deployment it looks like and that's
about it and also with please you can
actually use pleasings and then that's
like there's so many was for kubernetes
and docker containers and let me
actually show you
so um basically most of the times you
need to refer to specific images and
then as therefore name but right in here
you can just use the specific built
targets to specific docker images and it
would build it your book build it by
itself so yeah that's about it can you
grab there the microphone just off of
anyone sitting next to you and push the
button to talk so kubernetes is as far
as I understand it's very good for a non
parallel code you have a container and
you run that container it does this job
and then it shuts down if you want it to
shut down
can you use it for parallel jobs or for
big data requirements if I have a large
data set and I want to do the number
crunching where spark may be really good
for can docker and kubernetes do similar
things
um I think you could but because like
kubernetes can scale horizontally I
think you just need to assign like how
many of the pause and then it does it I
think you could do like parallel
processing on them too and then you can
also like do different okay parts as
well so add to the mic please first of
all I'm very I'm doing exactly that
parallel processing at the moment it's
possible you just have to do a bit of
managing on your own your data and
everything else is here you're just
scanning horizontal yeah you have a
service and a task no that's that's kind
of the key thing you have to scale
horizontally your workers and you have a
task now that finishes when it's done
with the data yep
yeah you might want to mention also that
you can pull different resources for
different services if you've got
machines for different different
requirements you can put them into the
mix do you use some kind of Orchestrator
like their floor something with the with
this and how does the deployment
interact with that if you use some kind
of Orchestrator I'm sorry what do you
use to control the tasks to create for
example to batch the the rent and etc um
we usually create specific scripts to
kind of run specific deployments and
usually we use that as a z' and it's
inside of and we create our own commands
for those scripts as well so usually um
at my place we just create specific
things kind of like create our product
and then everything kind of spawns up
inside of mini cube like locally anyways
my question was more like if you have to
run the same task every day mm-hmm so
for doing data wrangling from one place
to the other how are you controlling
that and the dependencies instead Oh we
do run this kind of jobs usually it's in
Jenkins
am I correct thinking the jury using I'm
sorry you're using KS only WS correct
yeah with my experience my WS ECS is
better it works out cheaper and has
better integration for example I am
rolls so what why did you go with KS if
it's a WS it has been night our kind of
setup for quite a while so we didn't
really change it after a while thank you
so my understanding of containers when
you put them into clusters like that is
because you're gonna be dropping them
building them and kind of low balance
and across different things it's best
for them to be completely stateless so
when you're working between different
environments you know between your
staging and your production environment
surely the underlying state store
whatever it is it's relatively different
between the two so how do you make sure
that you know as you're going from sort
of dummy fake staging data wherever that
sits and working of testing things
that's suddenly when you put into
production with actual people's data and
then you have to do schema change stuff
rather how does the point sister deal
with that sort of thing um what we
usually do is we usually create like
kind of dummy data if we know like um
what we can get you because usually we
get the data from API and we have like
sorry we have we would know how the data
might look like so we create a small set
of dummy data kind of just mirror that
kind of environment mm-hmm any other
questions okay
um yeah sorry just a question about the
mana Reapers
um so you say you're only checking in
the artifacts but surely you do still
want to check your code and not for
deployment but just for development
purposes so how does that work you have
to separate Reapers then I'm sorry the
microphone Elizabeth quiet with the mana
Reapers mm-hmm so you said you'd you're
only checking in the binaries and the
artifacts and not the code yes but
surely for development purposes you
still want to check your code into
Reaper somewhere yes yes on our local
machine anyways I think because our
repository is small enough to be checked
into one machine and so we still build a
specific part we still check in the
whole thing but from what I'm
understanding since like with Google
anyways they have like massive
repositories so they only have like a
small amount of the parts of the
repository that you work on and build it
and test it
well ring in your you're built set up
did you say that you use mini cube when
you built locally yes and so you do you
support this really builds with police
as well and how would they be
orchestrating sorry do use support
distributed builds with I think usually
with that we usually use like our own
made like um kind of bash file bash
scripts to do that yeah but usually like
with deployments you can kind of do
somewhat like that but I'd say usually
we usually do like specific scripts
specifically for kind of distributed
jobs yeah so we take one more question
yeah how do you or do you I guess do you
do any sort X or balances to check that
you don't end up with like cyclic
dependencies between different packages
or different areas of the repository
I'm sorry I think really are you pushing
the button it's gone really quiet
what dependencies are cyclical penances
actually I don't know I mean I tell you
that later I check it out fair enough
let's thank Luda
[Applause]